Hi, I'm [inaudible] and I'm doing the wired autocomplete interview.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
Is Dewey leaf. His real name. It's just early, but no middle name. That's it.
It's Albanian.
So that's why it probably sounds a bit weird to everyone.
What do a leap, a song are you,
I guess I I'd have to be all to them really. In some capacity.
What do a leap of fans are called?
There's no set name. I always just call them my loves.
They'd have to decide on their own. I can't, it's not my duty to,
to name them what was doing Deepa's first song.
The first song that I put out was called new love.
I put that out in 2015. Oh my God. When I look back on that video,
it's so crazy. What is daily? Pre-accident honestly,
I've no idea. British on most occasions.
Does Dua Lipa have a Grammy? I have to
feel so weird saying it does do Lipa speak Spanish. I don't,
but I wish I did. I feel like it's such a sexy language.
Maybe this should be my new year's resolution is learn Spanish.
Does do a leap of support Liverpool. Hmm.
How do I say this in the best way possible? I'm like, um,
can you say like honorary,
Liverpool supporter only because my dad and brother support arsenal,
and I think I'd be getting in a lot of trouble.
If I said that I just support Liverpool, but I love Liverpool.
It's always got a special place in my heart. It does do a leaper like anime.
I do. And my favorite anime is Ponyo.
It's the cutest I'm just obsessed with. It does do leave a play guitar.
I don't play guitar,
but I used to play the cello in school.
And then I got bullied about it a lot.
And so I quit and now I can't play anything.
How did do a leaper get discovered bit of a long
story, but I'll try and like shorten it a little bit. When I was young,
you know, I always wanted to make music.
I started making YouTube covers and I started showing them to my friends in
school.
And then I used them as like a form of portfolio to like work with different
producers and get in the studio. And I was like, you know,
I sing and I would love it. If we get in the studio and write together,
I made a bunch of demos and then I basically Googled managers in
London. And then I got offered like a publishing deal.
Then I had to find a lawyer.
And then the lawyer was trying to like help me and was like,
don't sign this publishing deal, whatever you do,
let me help you find a monitor. And he introduced me to my manager, Ben.
And so that was a really, really long story. Cut short.
How has Dua Lipa pronounced Dua Lipa? It's quite easy.
Although growing up,
I feel it was really difficult for lots of teachers and people to pronounce it.
How tall is Dua, Lipa feet,
five foot eight and feet
size six UK.
How to get Dua Lipa hair. Yeah. On occasion.
A lot of it is bought and glued in that's quite easy.
I felt like anyone could do that. But other than that,
I struggled to try and make it look nice. Bad hair days are kind of my thing.
What is homesick Lipa
about? It was really,
I'd spent so much time away from London and then it started pouring with rain in
Los Angeles. And it just made me miss London so much.
That's what homesick was about, was trying to get back home.
What do we leave per rules? Work hard and be nice.
What is duty? [inaudible] sign. I'm a Leo,
but I'm also a Libra rising and a cancer
moon. So I'm emotional as, but then really tough.
So don't mess with me. What is duly PPAs, middle name?
I don't have a middle name. That's just do a leaper kind of wish I did.
What is electricity do a lipo about?
It's about love feeling so electric and completely sending these
electric messages all up and down your spine and the feeling that you get when
you're falling in love. It's a fun song.
This was really a kind of turning point for me in terms of like confidence.
When I, when I shot the music video for electricity, it kind of changed my life.
I was like for the first time I was in front of cameras. I was very much in,
in the zone and I didn't really care what anybody was thinking and I just kind
of let it all out. And that song will always kind of represent that for me.
And I made that with my friends, Mark Ronson and Diplo.
So it's always more special when you get to do stuff with your mates can
do it, Eva, sing a bloody hope. So otherwise I'm like, why I'm doing it.
Can do a leap, a drive. I can drive. I actually passed my driving test.
First time I would always get public transport,
but I do really love the freedom of just getting in your car and going wherever
you want. Can duly per wrap only at karaoke.
That's where I like to rap. Cause I hate singing at karaoke. So I like to rap.
Can do it ever sing high notes. Um, I'm learning, I'm learning.
I definitely have such a low voice. So I've always struggled with high notes,
but I have been practicing and working with my vocal coach to be able to just
like expand my range and learn some new stuff. Okay.
Who is dually for siblings? I have two sons, siblings.
I have a younger brother and a younger sister.
My sister is cooled Rina and my brother's called Jen.
And they are the loves of my life who is dually for the singer.
Interesting on, so I, um,
I guess do it put the singer,
I guess a songwriter first and foremost and born and raised in London,
but via Kosovo, which is where my parents are from.
And so I always feel like I'm from two places at once. And I,
I also feel like that makes me who I am,
who is doing leap assigned to I'm signed to Warner brothers records first in the
UK and then in the U S and the rest of the world as well and
universal in Germany, who is doing the for stylist.
Oh my Amod at Lorenzo for SoCo. I love him.
I love collaborating with him. He's been with me for the longest time.
We've we've grown together and it's, it's been amazing.
Love him to pieces who is Dooley? His mum.
My mum is an angel sent from above. Her name is Anessa and she's my rock.
And my superhero, I wrote my first ever song when I was like four years old.
And it was about her. It was more like a joke of something at home.
It was an Albanian and it was all about when I grow up, can I wear your dress?
When I grow up, can I borrow your shoes? When I grow up,
can I be as pretty as you and still, my parents make fun of me sometimes.
And we still sing it to each other who is dearly,
has makeup artist today.
I have the wonderful Samantha who I love. She's amazing.
And she makes me feel like a million bucks was Dua Lipa in a
movie. No, I've never been in a movie. I don't know if I'm ready yet,
but I would love to do, at some point I enjoy acting. I just,
my main focus is always music was duly put on the voice.
No, I wasn't on the voice was do Lipa on X-Factor.
I wasn't on X-Factor but you know, earlier I said,
I did like a commercial and then I got offered like a publishing deal.
I did the commercial for the X-Factor, where I sang for one of their adverts.
And then I ended up working with a producer for it,
who then offered me the publishing deal. And then I didn't end up signing that,
but it was like a series of events that happened,
which then led to me getting to do what I always dreaded and of doing was doing
leave at the Grammys. We have been to the Grammy's a couple of times,
it's a ways really, really exciting. I have some incredible memories.
The, alright, we go last one are,
do any fat and Bebe Rexha related B when not
related, we are both Albanian. So I guess in that way,
I feel like all Albanian people call each other cousins or sisters or whatever.
Like you see an Albanian person on the street and you're like, yeah, yeah,
that's my cousin. But no, me and baby aren't related. I'm from Kosovo.
And I believe Bebe's from Macedonia, but we speak Albanian and we're very,
very proud to be Albanian. I do really fan action Bronson related again,
not related,
but I do see him as my big brother also got the crazy
Albanian roots and he also gives me the best restaurant recommendations of
old time. Finally do Lipa and Taylor, Swift friends.
I love Taylor. We've met a couple of times. She's amazing. One.
What an incredible artist done. Thank you so much for watching.
Feel free to Google any questions and maybe I'll be backing onto yours.